Now that we know how caches find
data when we are looking for it.
Let's talk about what happens when we
need to replace something from the cache
to make room for new data,
because we have a miss.
So the situation,
when we need replacement,
is the set where the data
needs to go is full.
We have a miss, so
we need somewhere to put the new
block that we are bringing in.
And we need to put it in that set.
And the question for cache replacement
is which of the blocks in the set do we
kick out to make room for the new one?
Possible replacement policies are,
random.
Just pick a block randomly from
those that are in the set.
FIFO, which kicks out the block
that has been there the longest.
So in FIFO,
let's say we have two blocks.
We bring in A, then we bring B.
When we want to bring in C,
we're going to kick out A because
it's been there the longest.
Then we're going to kick out
B to bring D, and so on.
The next policy is LRU or
Least Recently Used.
We want to kick out the block that
has not been used the longest.
So we definitely don't want to kick
out the block that is the most
recently used.
And then the next most recently,
and so on.
So pretty much we track which
block has been used more recently.
And when we need to replace something,
we choose the block that we
haven't used for the longest time.
It turns out that LRU is
a really good policy.
So, there are several policies that are
trying to approximate it because this is
not easy to do.
One such policy, for example,
is NMRU or Not Most Recently Used,
which tracks just which block has
been used the most recently, and
then picks randomly among
the remaining blocks.
So pretty much,
don't pick the block that was just used.